pilote nous nous trouvons dans une loge
du théâtre olympia montréal où sera
donné le coup d'envoi du grand montréal
comédie fest dimanche un brin nerveuse
je dirais que je suis fébrile g j'ai
hâte devant le spectacle j'ai hâte de
voir la réaction des gens aussi parce
que je pense que ça va être un festival
différent moi parce que c'était un pari
soit fait cela qui a été créé dans la
foulée de la sphère rozon oui
donc c'est un grand saut dans le but de
lopo plusieurs au monde un petit miracle
je dirais ce festival là parce que
monter au festival ainsi moi c'est
c'est complètement fou c'est pas pour
rien que c'est écrit sur les affiches
c'est fou mais ça s'est fait parce que
il y avait cette volonté lors de faire
un festival coups sûrs
avez vous réussi à atteindre la parité
homme femme sur scène pour ce festival
passe je suis fier de dire qu on a 32 %
de femmes considérant qu'il ya moins de
fans morisques d'homme c'est vraiment
très très bon ratio il ya environ 25
familles modestes qui vont être sur le
gala y en a qui vont jouer à plusieurs
reprises et je pense qu'au québec on ne
jamais vu son jeune âge
je t'aime à l'émotion retour en arrière
votre carrière habitants 1984 vous étiez
la reprise du groupe sans dsk ne dis pas
que c'était difficile pour un enfant de
père se faire sa place dans n'importe
quel métier non traditionnel je pense
que c'est de rester là longtemps qui est
ici c'est de ne pas se reconnaître dans
les personnes avec qui tu évolues moi à
l'époque où je faisais de l'humour bon
mais y avait peut-être une dizaine de
spectacles en tournée
aujourd'hui un au dessus de 50 alors là
la compétition est aussi forte autant
pour les jeunes garçons que les jeunes
filles oh je suis gaulin dispute human
confiance hier et auteur du best seller
fut midi soit belle et femmes noires
le pugiliste à ce que vous trouvez qu'à
l'époque il ya certaines choses qu'il ne
souffrait plus aujourd'hui
oui les collines je pense en l'espace de
six mois son regard d'alain avons mis
tous il y avait une manière de faire du
mot il y en eu une après donc elle
imagine en 1900 son conte par 80 cas pas
aujourd'hui a évidemment l'humour
énormément évolué
oui je laisse un homme ose lui allait
aller bouchard récupère en navarre et
même tellement d'ailleurs je me dis
beaucoup moins jusque quatre fois par
jour
mais s'il est là l'enfant numéro sur
l'omx où je faisais je parlais des
hommes rouges jazzy et funky ou des
ménages et ça marchait ça marchait
aujourd'hui bomba les hongrois ou non
pas depuis d'autres centres c'est comme
mais c'est normal ça évolue de céder à
laymont agaguk mathon fermont dans mon
nunavut et dépose - héritier dans le bas
canada
pourquoi avez vous décidé en certain
moment de quitter la scène pour vous
consacrer à d'autres projets devenir par
exemple une femme d'affaires quand je
faisais j'avais toujours aimé la tournée
moi j'en ai fait pendant 16 ans temps
sans arrêt avec le groupe sanguin pense
que tout seul et je t'aime fait deux
tournées jeunesse au sortir d'un bar à
prêt à aller voir le monde dans les
villes mais quand j'ai recommencé après
treize ans d'absence sur scène quand
j'ai recommencé je me suis rendu compte
qu on pouvait pas être revue parce qu'on
avait vécu le même manière j'ai vieilli
j'ai envie de soupe et le soir dans les
podiums g et et je pense que je
ressemble plus le jeu pas j'avais
quelque chose à me prouver je je ressens
plus le besoin de faire applaudir jeu
je trouve que les yeux énormément de
compétition la tournée se fait plus
comme cela se faisait avant
alors j'ai comme fait aube j'ai eu du
fun à faire le show mais je pense que ça
va être mon dernier show bouclons la
boucle
oui plusieurs sceptiques affirme que le
grand montréal communiste est ne
survivra pas l'édition 2018 que répondez
vous à vos détracteurs à les sceptiques
seront confondus
je crois que le grand montréal comédie
cesse de prendre de l'ampleur avec
l'autre je le crois profondément à l'ex
pilote
merci ça me fait plaisir